dave ist schon seit tagen wieder ein
projekt machen indem er sich irgendwie
hoch arbeiten kann hoch train kann hier
auch immer und ich dachte mir das hier
ist ein guter anfang ich gebe der f 1
euro und 24 stunden zeit um sich so hoch
zufrieden wie es nur irgendwie geht
neben diesen euro und vermehre ihm
innerhalb von 24 stunden auch so viel
wie kein eur 24 stunden
[Musik]
überlegt das los geht's also es stimmt
schon seit dem rolex trade ob zu ende
ist wenn ich irgendwie ein bisschen
planen muss ich habe riesiges loch in
mir weil das mein baby war und ich
eigentlich wieder sowas in richtung
machen wird umso besser dass max mir
diese entscheidung jetzt abgenommen hat
24 stunden zeit 14 uhr 50 hier die
bestätigung wir starten es ist noch nie
jemand ohne planrecht geworden das ding
jetzt ich habe so viele videos schon zu
dem thema gemacht dass ich fast alles
schon gemacht habe ein paar sachen aber
noch nicht die immer noch auf den listen
stehen das bedeutet ich durchforste hat
die listen eine sache die mir direkt an
gefallen ist ist blutspenden dafür
kriegt man instant 25 euro
aufwandsentschädigung das ist kein lohn
oder aufwandsentschädigung aber man kann
sich sofort und 20 euro abholen darf ich
den euro gegen online euro eintauschen
sonst komme ich nicht zum blutspenden du
kannst du deine einfallen
also auf den roller gesprungen und mit
gold für 50 cent die minute zum
blutspenden gedüst
plätze der
[Musik]
kostenträger
ich kann einfach im blut spenden welchen
perfekte wohnung gehabt das muss ein
anderer plan her das war wohl nix
doch was das problem war
was war das problem
ich
will jetzt aber auf dem weg zurück ist
nach einem weg denn blut ist ja nicht
die einzige körperflüssigkeit die
spenden kann und das ist schwer es ist
tatsächlich möglich schwer marc zu
spenden ich habe schon diverse male
davon gehört ich habe mich immer davor
gedrückt dass irgendwann irgend welche
videos zu benutzen aber heute ist der
tag gekommen wo ich bereit wäre
durchzuziehen
ich habe eine samenbank gefunden ich
werde anrufen und fragen wie viel kohle
kommt warum kann ich das sofort machen
und ist es möglich dass mein
potenzieller sohn mich dann irgendwann
kontaktiert oder meint meine tochter
oder meine tochter
ich werde gleich mal die samen sprinten
schlecht dann schauen wir was das
internet so an informationen für uns zu
bieten hat alter zwischen 18 38 sie
sollten sich bester gesundheit erfreut
erbkrankheit nein chronische erkrankung
nein die aufwandsentschädigung beträgt
150 euro pro springen gut jetzt ist nur
die frage dürfen nicht meine kids dann
irgendwann kontaktieren
dürfen kinder tier sagen hessen ein
spender kinder haben ein recht zu
erfahren wer ihr genetischer vater ist
der spender ist an sich seine spende
mega gutes ding so können paare die
keine möglichkeit haben selber zu
zweiten kind zu zeugen ein kind zeugen
das super das wort ich wahrscheinlich
eine ziemlich gute option um jetzt ganz
schnell die ersten 150 euro mit denen
hätten wir investieren können sachen
kaufen können die wir weiter verkaufen
meine motivation ist aber irgendwie
nicht die richtige und ich möchte
irgendwann
erzeuger kind nicht zwangsläufig
kennenlernen müssen ich glaube das wird
nichts aber was soll's ich habe diverse
der andere tolle foto und video
auftragsarbeit das ding ist ich habe
schon lange nicht mehr gemacht ich habe
keine festen kunden anrufen kann um zu
sagen hey ich kann nicht was für dich
machen ich muss quasi auf dem street
leute erwischen für dich arbeiten kann
das kriegen wir aber hin das werden wir
gleich probieren davor aber werden wir
gucken ob wir sagen bei ebay
kleinanzeigen finden die zu verschenken
sind wir mal eigentlich noch ein wärter
die wollen wir dann einfach kostenlos
irgendwo ab und verkaufen sie weiter
bereiten sie vielleicht ein bisschen auf
wenn es um ihnen welche möbel oder so
geht denn ich aber diverse city top's
und kurzvideos gesehen bedeutet günstige
möbel gekauft haben aufbereitet und für
viel teurer verkauft haben das werde ich
auch probieren nur mit geschenken würden
wir suchen macht und schauen was zu
finden können aber warum das ganze
eigentlich was habe ich überhaupt mit
dem geld vor was sich hoffentlich in den
nächsten 24 stunden verdiene hier kommt
ein langfristiger partner timeless im
spiel hatte mir gesagt dass du tolle
news für mich hast aber ich vorher nicht
erfahren dürfte um was es sich denn
handeln würde ja bitte
[Applaus]
wenn du dir jetzt ein asset aus und wenn
ja was ich war neulich eingeladen auf
dem handy saß mir ein bild im kopf
geblieben und cro custom dein wort
gehalten hast und auf mein anraten
einfachen konzept von groh organisiert
ist sehr stark
richtig gut also tatsächlich dropped
jetzt am 31 einfach anmelden und davon
gar nicht anteile kaufen denn der wird
gibt euch kennen das die möglichkeit
anteile an kollekte wird es kaufen autos
kunst wein oder eben im bild funktion
alle kollekte wird werden von timeless
verwaltet und sicher gelagert was ist
henning für euch super easy und
unkompliziert und falls euch das konzept
von grau aus irgendeinem grund noch
nicht genug seien solche brocken am
selben tag noch zwei unterschriebene
andy warhol apps ab ein wahrhafter john
4 und direkt 2011 jahr klappt es also
völlig neues lineup klingt also jetzt
auf den erdlingen der video beschreibung
um euch 10 euro startguthaben zu sichern
mit denen ihr euch direkt einen
kostenlosen anteil eines wettkampfes
sichern könnte aber nicht nur dass
sobald die 10 euro startguthaben
investiert habt nehmt ihr automatisch am
gewinnspiel teil bei den sechs teilen
des portfolios im wert von 10.000 euro
die teilnahmebedingungen stehen direkt
unter dem registrierungs link in der
video beschreibung vielen dank dass sie
mich um diese gesamte projekt sie
unterstützen und möglich machen checkt
den link in der video schreiben braucht
jetzt viel spaß weiter mit dem video
gefunden habe ich einen ledersessel eine
vitrine einen schreibtisch und diverse
hunde und katzen interessanter als der
hund und katzen waren natürlich alle
möbelstücke mit den anbietern habe ich
direkt geschrieben pastoren ich bin
gerade auf seine anzeige gestoßen
blablabla erstmal auf antworten warten
was genau daraus geworden ist erfahrt
ihr später im video vorerst kümmern wir
uns um foto und video produktion wo
sollte ich eher starten als auf der
aachener straße alles voll mit bars mit
restaurants mit
restaurants und bars ja eigentlich ist
genau das was wir brauchen ich werde
einfach reinstetten werde die leute
einfach fragen ob ich für sie fotos und
videos machen kann für social media und
vor allem werde ich die sachen bis heute
abend noch abheben beziehungsweise bis
morgen früh wenn ich die komplette nacht
durcharbeiten muss und wir super viele
leute finden die lust darauf haben
gestalten bei print zuschiebt den besten
lernen können sich tatsächlich dem
besitzer kenne und ich probiere der ein
bisschen geld abzuluchsen wir gehen
neben gehört der laden hier den kennen
wir schon max hat hier seinen
bürgerladen gemacht ich möchte gerne
fotos und videos für den social media
machen das wichtig für die damit deinen
laden weiter wächst und so natürlich und
ich würde hier so schön alles april gute
figur machen und geschichte bis heute
abend
heißt auch kohle dafür
150 das aber ernst fehr oder 25 150 ich
habe ja extra von freundschaftspreisen
und angesetzt
[Musik]
danke
ich habe direkt gemerkt dass ich stark
aus der übung finden seitdem lebe meine
videos kostet und auch dreht stehe ich
natürlich viel häufiger vor als hinter
der kamera zwar ein paar minuten
gedauert aber ich habe trotzdem gut
reingefunden und es hat wunderbar
funktioniert
[Musik]
1944 wir haben genau 150 euro verdient
was absolut unter dem ist was ich mir
vorgestellt habe nachdem wir den ganzen
tag komplett auseinander genommen wurden
erst mal eine runde dann wollte ich kein
kind zeugen und dann haben wir die ganze
zeit absagen bekommen nichtsdestotrotz
sitze ich am schritt vom prince
zustimmung das weil ich durch und dann
gilt es für mich eine möglichkeit finden
jetzt heute abend noch irgendwie online
kohle zu verdienen oder so irgendwelche
sachen zu finden die ich morgen früh
ganz schnell abholen kann um sie dann
weiterzuverkaufen ihr könnt was das
reicht definitiv
was soll ich sagen wir haben bei ebay
kleinanzeigen keine einzige antwort
erhalten nicht mal ab sagt mit
verbleibenden fünfeinhalb stunden fällt
ebay kleinanzeigen und das aufbereiten
von möbeln also definitiv raus weil
einfach zu wenig zeit ist das einzige
was bis dato wirklich funktioniert hatte
war foto und video produktion also habe
ich mir gedacht never change a running
system ich brauche neue foto und video
kunden ich bin zu kaffee kaffee auf der
aachener straße gegangen und habe dort
auf 1 einen neuen auftrag gefunden weil
es mir irgendwie unangenehm war habe ich
die kamera beim ersten kontakt nicht
laufen lassen aber was soll ich sagen
das hat wieder funktioniert genau das
war s creek action-reihe akten zu 850
euro abholen hat nach hause in den
schnitt sehr sehr nice sehr sehr nah ist
wirklich
also direkt wieder ins büro und an den
schnitt gesetzt fotos fertig bearbeitet
wofür ich gerade mal eine stunde
gebraucht habe die letzte möglichkeit
jetzt noch irgendwie in den letzten paar
stunden was rauszuholen war also viel
marketing oder irgendwie online geld zu
verdienen das problem ist bei meiner
bank wo ist eigentlich meine freunde
werben kommt womit ich 25 euro pro
geworbenen freund hätte verdienen können
wurde das konzept komplett abgeschafft
also musste ich eine weitere option
finden habe das internet absolut
durchforstet und bin irgendwo in den
tiefsten reddot foren auf die liste
gekommen von sachen bei denen man
innerhalb von kürzester zeit geld und
ein punkt war eingesparten emissionen zu
verkaufen werden ganz kurz was zur hölle
ist dass firmen dürfen bestimmt viel
emissionen produzieren wenn sie diese
überschreiten müssen sie co2 zertifikate
von beispielsweise anderen firmen kaufen
die co2 eingespart haben damit sie
weiter produzieren können jetzt ist das
denk ich habe einen test land ein paar
leute um mich herum haben tesla und alle
diese autos sparen emissionen frauen
weniger emissionen in die umwelt als sie
dürfen das bedeutet alle leute den
vollelektrisches auto fahren sparen
emission ein und kein witz jetzt wird
krass auf der website geld - für -
auto.de punkt noch ganz vielen anderen
anbietern ist es möglich seinen
fahrzeugschein hochzuladen der beweis
dass man ein elektroauto fährt und damit
mindestens
275 euro ausgezahlt zu bekommen weil die
die eingesparten emissionen von einem
abkaufen das ist ziemlich krass
natürlich darf ich die eingesparten
emissionen von meinem eigenen auto nicht
benutzen ich kann aber alle leute um
mich herum die e auto haben anrufen
abtelefonieren und sie darum bitten dass
wir uns genau diese prämierten ohne mich
wissen sie nicht dass es diese
möglichkeit gibt ich nehme ihnen die
komplette arbeit ab ich fragte sie nach
ihren fahrzeugschein und ich werde alles
für sie das bedeutet sie schicken ihren
fahrzeugschein ich lasse ihn hoch für
das komplette formular für sie außer
überhaupt keinen stress und wir erhalten
gemeinsam 275 euro davon möchte ich
gerne und shell haben und zwar 50
prozent jetzt telefoniere ich alle leute
ab die ein auto haben und dann schauen
wir wie viel geld verdienen können
hallo
kai
strichen sie dort läuft alles frisch
frech und ich suche leute die ein
elektroauto haben den autor ist ja nach
wie vor weg
ich möchte dir aber ein wenig aus dem
schlamassel helfen und du kannst mir
damit auch etwas helfen ich würde das
gerne komplett für dich machen das
komplett für dich übernehmen und das
gerne 50 50 mit detail
ja
ja ja der ist sehr ist noch besser wenn
der stamm weil er hatte ja gar keine
emissionen verbraucht ja
ja ja
ja kein problem
na ja es wird immer besser ich habe
jetzt noch auf der website gesehen ladet
eine e auto freunde ein und er hat jeden
morgen und eine 50 euro bonus nach einer
anmeldung bei uns erhält sie von uns
einen persönlichen linken und mit deinen
freunden teilen kannst zum einen teil
ich bin mit euch das hier ist der link
ist auch eine video beschreibung könnt
ihr euch an beiden weniger auto habt und
mindestens 275 euro prämie abholen und
außerdem kann ich die leute die mir
nicht 50 abgeben wollen was bis dato
nicht der fall war was aber theoretisch
passieren könnte über einen link auf die
website schicken sie bekommen 275 euro
und ich bekomme noch 50 euro kaufen mega
entstand wirklich also ein hoch auf die
e-autos das ist eine absolute cashflow
ich weiß nicht ob ich jemals schon mal
so einfach geld verdient hat gamestop
wir haben 14 59 zitieren die 24 stunden
sind rum ich habe probiert in den
letzten stunden alle leute zu
mobilisieren die ich nur im
entferntesten kenne mit einem
elektroauto um für sie ihre eingesparten
emissionen zu verkaufen insgesamt hat
das nur für zwei leute gereicht einmal
kelly vielen dank herr ist eine absolute
ehre frau und ein mann liegt dessen auto
tatsächlich gar nicht benutzt wurde
richtig neu ist damit konnte ich zwei
mal 137 euro 50 bekommen die beiden foto
und video aufträge haben jeweils 150
euro gebracht auch noch riesen dank
annahmen von print zu schieben ich würde
euch tatsächlich raten wenn ihr geld
verdienen wollte wenn ihr euch
ausprobieren wollt macht es erstmal bei
bekannten freunden von bekannten usw in
sachen nicht richtig laufen könnt ihr
das super easy mit dem regeln ist viel
einfacher als wenn ihr direkt mit
entfernten kunden erarbeitet vielen dank
nahmen insgesamt bin ich mega happy mit
dem ergebnis bin mega fertig weil ich
tatsächlich erst dann relativ wenig
geschlafen habe die ganze zeit noch nach
möglichkeiten gesucht habe und so weiter
vielen dank an zwei - fürs unterstützen
dieses videos wenn euch das video
gefallen hat was wir gerne like da und
vergesst nicht den kanal zu abonnieren
wenn ihr wollt dass diesmal über 7 oder
30 tage versuchen lasst es mich in den
kommentaren wissen ich mache jetzt
erstmal ein problem
[Musik]